c'est un moment où nous avons nous
savons que la justice souffre est en
difficulté que les États généraux ont
tiré un certain nombre de conclusions
qui d'ailleurs vont dans le même sens
que les observations qui ont été faites
depuis longtemps par par le Sénat et
qu'il était important que le garde des
sceaux nous dit ce qu'il va faire nous
arrivons dans la période budgétaire
d'une part et d'autre part nous avons
besoin de connaître ces lignes
directrices après ce rapport donc il
fallait l'interroger c'était ça l'enjeu
utile on a pas le temps d'aborder tous
les sujets il en reste quand même qui
pose difficulté c'est celui en matière
pénale de l'exécution des peines de la
rapidité de cette exécution de leur
efficacité et donc des moyens qui seront
mis pour cette exécution sur ce point là
nous n'avons pas eu d'éléments de
réponse mais nous allons continuer de de
combattre et surtout de d'essayer de
savoir comment les choses sont
organisées car c'est absolument
stratégique
[Musique]
cela fait 20 ans qu'on ne met pas les
moyens nécessaires dans le monde de la
justice donc aujourd'hui nous manquons à
la fois de magistrats nous manquons de
greffiers et j'ai pu m'en rendre compte
lors d'un stage d'immersion que j'ai
fait au tribunal de Bordeaux et j'ai pu
voir sur place et d'ailleurs les
magistrats en ont fait pas de l'état de
souffrance de la magistrature et du
personnel judiciaire donc on est dans
une situation qui est aujourd'hui
critique et il va falloir trouver les
moyens pour que cette justice puisse
faire son travail et à côté de ça on a
bien sûr l'incompréhension des personnes
qui ne comprennent pas pourquoi et bien
les peines ne sont pas assez lourdes
pourquoi et bien certaines personnes
sont remis relativement rapidement en
liberté et tout cela et bien je pense
que c'est également lié au fait qu'il
nous manque aujourd'hui en France des
prisons des maisons d'arrêt dans la
proposition qui avait fait Emmanuel
Macron il y avait 15000 places de prison
qui avaient été prévues or aujourd'hui
on en à 7000 il nous manque donc des
places et effectivement l'année dernière
j'avais dénoncé d'ailleurs l'état de nos
prisons et le fait que ces prisonniers
soient dans des situations également
dramatiques ce qui ne perd pas une permé
pas la réinsertion ensuite et leur
permettre de retrouver une vie normale
au moment où il sortiront dans les
meilleures conditions
[Musique]